Speaker 1: Rudy Giuliani who was recently
accused of being drunk on election night during
which he told Donald Trump, just claim that
you won and gave him all sorts of other authoritarian
advice that led to months and months and really
at this point, years of Trump and others insisting
that Trump actually won.
Rudy Giuliani initially tweeted that he was
not drunk on election night and he has quietly
deleted those tweets.
The obvious speculation is Rudy deleted the
tweets because there's going to be undeniable
evidence that Rudy was actually drunk out
of his mind on election night.
So let's go through this piece by piece.
Rudy Giuliani deletes tweets denying he was
drunk on election night.
Explosive claim was made by fellow campaign
staffer.
So as a reminder, I know many of you already
saw this clip.
One of the big things at the start of the
second day of hearings with the Trump Riot
Committee was Liz Cheney explaining that Rudy
Giuliani in an inebriated state was the one
telling Trump, just declare victory.
Speaker 3: You will hear firsthand testimony
that the president's campaign advisers urged
him to await the counting of votes and not
to declare victory on election night.
The president understood even before the election
that many more Biden voters had voted by mail
because President Trump ignored the advice
of his campaign experts and told his supporters
only to vote in person.
Donald Trump knew before the election that
the counting of those mail in ballots in several
states would not begin until late in the day
and would not be complete for multiple days.
This was expected, reported and widely known.
You will also hear testimony that President
Trump rejected the advice of his campaign
experts on election night and instead followed
the course recommended by an apparently inebriated
Rudy Giuliani.
Right.
To just claim he won and insist that the vote
counting stop to falsely claim everything
was fraudulent.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Okay.
So initially Rudy Giuliani tweeted, refuting,
denying these claims.
Rudy tweeting not long ago, quote, I am disgusted
and outraged at the outright lie by Jason
Miller and Bill Stepien.
I was upset that they were not prepared for
the massive cheating as well as other lawyers
around the president.
I refused all alcohol that evening.
My favorite drink, Diet Pepsi, is the false
testimony from Miller and Stepien because
I yelled at them.
Are they being paid to lie?
Well, Rudy Giuliani has now deleted those
tweets.
Rudy Giuliani has deleted two tweets in which
the former mayor and attorney for Trump denied
being drunk as votes rolled in on election
night and advising the president to declare
victory.
The two tweets disappeared from Giuliani's
timeline sometime Tuesday evening.
What is the most simple explanation for this?
Well, the simplest explanation is someone
is going to come forward with specific knowledge
of Rudy being drunk that night.
Either it's very he's he said very not only
did see, here's the problem.
Not only did Rudy deny being drunk, he said
he refused all alcohol.
So because Rudy went above and beyond in his
denial.
If there is any evidence that he had any alcohol
that night, he now is a liar.
You could say I was not drunk.
I had a drink, I was not drunk.
And then if someone comes forward and says,
here's a picture of Rudy with a drink, you're
not necessarily an obvious liar.
Rudy still is a liar, of course, but you're
not necessarily an obvious liar here.
It's a different thing where Rudy said, I
refused alcohol the entire evening.
Now, as a as a reminder, we're not making
fun of alcoholism if that is something Rudy
struggles with.
There are widespread reports that during the
Trump presidency, the schedulers around Trump
started booking Rudy Giuliani for morning
TV shows rather than evening, because it turned
out that in the evenings he would allegedly
show up drunk after having a bunch of drinks
at dinner.
We also have videos like this one, which,
again, I know some of you have seen, but where
he genuinely seems completely wasted.
Speaker 3: Tony Blinken or Miley Hunter, how
is that guy a general Jesus?
He has a day, he said, at the Bagram Air Force
Base.
It's not strategically important.
I wanted to grab him.
What do you have?
Five stars.
Ten stars, 12 stars.
So many stars to come to his ears.
I wanted to grab his stars, shove it down
his throat and say it's 400 miles in China,
asshole.
Speaker 1: China?
Yeah.
So anyway, the real issue here is there were
people on election night around Trump telling
him the truth, which is you lost.
But Trump ignored all of them and just accepted
what he wanted to hear from an allegedly drunk
Rudy Giuliani, which is you probably want
to just go out and declare victory.
That's the really crazy part of the story.
Rudy deleting the tweets just points more
in the direction of the testimony being accurate.